She kept her
cabin pretty clean.
Now you walk into this
place of shambles.
It's like night and day.
The house was just smashed.
It almost seemed like
someone was in a rage.
The holes into her
bedroom, it was quite obvious
the tin had been cut and
had been pulled back.
How could somebody have
cut that much and not made
a tremendous amount of noise?
And why was that not something
that was an alarm for Dian?
Why wouldn't she flee?
Why wouldn't she, you know?
So how did she end up being
killed right there by her bed?
I had once in my
life seen a dead body.
And I certainly
never expected to see
a person who had been a victim
of murder, violent murder.
And it was somebody I knew.
You know, it was Dian.
From the story she told
me, putting pieces together,
man, she was really right
about what she said.
Dian had made enemies with
a lot of people over time.
But we never expected
her to be murdered.